do you think you're rich here's what
Americans say about you being rich
uh according to the 2023 modern wealth
survey by Charles Schwab Americans
believe it takes 2.2 million dollars to
be considered wealthy but those who feel
wealthy today have an average net worth
of 560 000 it's pretty interesting
that's a you know small amount the
survey reveals that 62 percent of
Americans prioritize healthy
relationship as a key indicator of
wealth while 70 believe wealth is more
about not having to stress over money
social media impacts wealth perceptions
about with 47 percent of Americans
saying being able to afford a lifestyle
comparable to their friends makes them
feel wealthy additionally 37 percent
compared their lifestyle to what family
and friends share on social media
and 34 make purchase decisions based on
what they see on social media
interesting Adam thoughts well you know
how big he used to say Mo Money Mo
Problems uh he had that one wrong let me
tell you something uh Kanye I think had
it uh said uh way better he said
um having money isn't everything but not
having it is
um let me tell you something when you
have money in your life
all the little things all the little
problems all the little annoyances oh
flat tire oh traffic ticket oh monthly
rent do whatever none of those issues
matter any point and then what happens
is if you don't do what these other
people are doing and basically just keep
up with the Joneses and just follow what
people uh are buying on social media or
what people are doing what family and
friends and you you know are doing uh
that you're basically trying to keep up
with you can actually help the ones
around you and I think that's what I I
liked about this relationship is they're
prioritizing healthy relationships
um in their life to basically help the
people around you and I think that's
something that that you even you abide
by I see what you do with family friends
vacations parties I think that's what
the essence of life is when you have
money is empowering the people around
you like I just took my mom to Israel
cost me a good amount of money to go out
and travel but like that was great a
great investment in my time
um I I constantly help out friends that
are in need remember my buddy that we
went to dinner with that one time uh
with the basketball player at The Yard
House his kids becoming a great
basketball player he's like listen I'm
running low on funds like I want to take
them to
uh travel this summer and Basketball
Camp can I get a loan I'm like I got you
bro this is for your kid so that's what
I found when since I have money now and
I think that that I have like Financial
Freedom the best return on investment is
a investing in myself B helping the
people around me and then lastly buying
things that I think
um you know are nice and they're fun but
the last point that I'll say is this you
know they say the comparison is the
thief of Joy
um don't compare yourself to what other
people have what you should do is
compare yourself to where you were two
years ago five years ago ten years ago
and that should be the barometer for
your wealth
um
it really also comes down to age so for
instance if you're 40 don't compare
yourself to a 60 year old if you're 20
don't compare yourself to a 40 year old
so like look at pbd let's let's use them
as an example
judge yourself on where you were five
years ago 10 years ago clearly you've
done well but don't compare yourself to
let's say Grant Cardone he's 65 years
old I didn't realize how old that guy
was I Googled it the other day homie 65.
now allegedly he's worth a half a
billion dollars or a billion I shouldn't
compare myself to Grant Cardinal is that
what you just said I'm saying that by
the time you're 65. have you ever heard
me talk about Grant card zero ever not
I'm gonna weird I'm embarrassing this
guy the reason that I'm doing this
before the reason that I'm doing it is
because he's 20 years older but but
that's a very terrible analogy because
I've never compared myself to Grand car
I'm not I'm not saying that you find the
point you're making I understand what
you're saying here right now but that
was kind of weird for you to say uh uh
I'm just saying I'm just saying he's way
older than you so you shouldn't compare
yourself to a Warren Buffett and I think
he's killing it in ways that for him to
be in in the physical shape that he is
and doing what he's doing you're making
a point about don't compare yourself to
other people in different places uh I do
believe
in having positive peer pressure around
you to make you step up and challenge
yourself as much as possible I think you
need to be around an environment here's
what happens with positive peer pressure
in a positive peer pressure one of two
things happens unfortunately I've seen
this in the last 20 something years
one either you cave and you quit and you
go to a more safer environment where it
doesn't give you the kind of pressure
that you're not giving your best or you
wake up one day and you're like damn
look who I've turned into very
impressive who I am today it's a it's a
it's a necessary thing to do to have
positive peer pressure around you but
the part where I said I can't believe
that's uh that's not a lot of money
wasn't a 2.2 million for me was the uh
what do you call it the 560 thousand
dollars yeah what do you say it said it
said what about 500 it says Those Who
feel wealthy today have an average net
worth of 560 000
560 000 is not a lot of money today it's
just not a lot of money today uh uh and
also it has to do with your age but it's
not a lot of money today when you're
looking at retirement close range things
like that hey if you enjoyed this short
hope you want to watch the whole thing
click over here but if you want to make
2023 the beginning of the greatest years
of your life I host a conference once
years called The Vault conference where
3 000 CEOs executive entrepreneurs from
around the world come together to
strategize for three and a half days
this year it's going to be at Miami
Diplomat Resort and the speakers this
year is going to be Tom Brady he'll be
there I'll be interviewing them Mike
Tyson will gudara the guy that ran 11
Madison in New York if you run a
business if you're a CEO entrepreneur
and executive this is not an event you
want to miss out on get yourself your
spouse your business partner your
running mates registered and I look
forward to seeing you there click on the
link here or see the link in the
description and I hope to spend three
and a half days with you in Miami in
August and September take care everybody
thank you